québec va encadrer les agences
d'évaluation de crédit equifax et
transunion des entreprises privées
seront dorénavant sous la supervision de
l'autorité des marchés financiers elles
devront permettre aux consommateurs qui
le désirent de verrouiller leur crédit
c'est-à-dire d'empêcher que les
informations de leurs dossiers soient
utilisés pour l'octroi de nouveaux prêts
les agences devront aussi offrir une
alerte de sécurité efficaces les
institutions financières devront
effectuer des vérifications
supplémentaires
lorsqu'une alerte sera inscrite au
dossier de crédit d'un consommateur
on en parle avec eric girard le ministre
des finances bonsoir monsieur girard
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en quoi
votre projet de loi va éviter une autre
affaire desjardins c'est à dire que ici
ce que nous venons faire c'est encadrer
les agences d'évaluation de crédit qui
sont des joueurs extrêmement important
dans le système financier canadien ces
îles sont les intermédiaires entre les
consommateurs qui font des demandes de
crédits et les institutions financières
qui octroie le crédit alors et ses
agences la détiennent énormément de
renseignements personnels sur les
consommateurs et offre des services qui
sont très importants notamment le
service d'alerté et il nous voulons
qu'ils offrent un service supplémentaire
c'est-à-dire le verrou crédit seul le
verrou c'est pour protéger les clients
en cas de vol d'identité donc verrous
moi je veut geler monde aussi crédit je
vais pouvoir le faire comme aux états
unis
exactement et ça ce n'est pas disponible
au canada c'est un service que nous
allons exiger des agences de crédit
supplémentaire pour les québécois et ça
ça veut dire qu'une institution
financière ou n'importe qui l'a n'aura
pas accès à mon dossier de crédit
exactement c'est à dire que c'est le
consommateur qui soupçonne qu'il a été
victime d'un vol d'identité qui aura le
pouvoir de verrouiller et déverrouiller
son dossier est donc lorsqu'une
institution financière voudrait octroyer
du crédit
elle devra
il devrait y avoir le verrou d'oeuvre a
été enlevé par ce matin jusque là il
faut il faut avoir le soupçon que nos
données sont en danger
moi ce soir si je veux ce soir ou quand
le projet de loi sera adopté là si je
décide que je verrouille mon dossier de
crédit est ce que je vais pouvoir le
faire un point ce soir
non mais une fois que la loi sera adopté
oui ben hilli aaron est une des mesures
transitoires parce que étant donné que
des outils technologiques qui doivent
être implantés il y aura une période de
transition où d'abord le projet de loi
devant et étudier adopté ensuite la et
marif qui va être le superviseur des
agences d'évaluation de crédit vont
émettre des lignes directrices pour les
pâtes les pratiques commerciales les
pratiques de gestion est énoncé qui est
une agence d'évaluation crédit des
désignés on parle d'équipé axés
transunion au canada et non c'est leur
responsabilité est long mais je suis
bien content si si je n'ai pas de doute
que mes données vont être volés ou ont
été volés au lieu une fuite ou quoi que
ce soit est ce que je pourrai décider de
geler mon dossier de crédit
oui mais c'est un service qui sera
offert alors normalement je veux essayer
le système d' alerte vise la prévention
alors si vous vous avez été victime d'un
vol de données et vous voulez et qu'il
ya un signal dans votre dossier de
crédit qui demande aux institutions
financières qui serait intéressé à
octroyer du coût du crédit de faire des
vérifications supplémentaires ça c'est
le service d' alerte et c'est de la
prévention
si vous croyez que vous avez été victime
d'un vol de données
le haut ou d'un rouge les identités vous
pouvez gelé votre crédit et empêcher
toute question d'accéder à votre dossier
et la mmf va s'assurer qu'ils fax fait
un bon travail
exactement aux mêmes la meuf va
réglementer les agences d'évaluation
crédit est-ce que
on a été servis pas mal en anglais
l'appareil fax dans les dernières
semaines dans les derniers mois mais
vous mettez pas d'obligation qui fax
donne son service en français dans votre
projet de loi pourquoi stade il ya eu un
processus de consultation dans le projet
de loi on ya pensé et on a réalisé que
ce n'était pas nécessaire parce que
equifax doit offrir des services en
français selon la législation actuelle
les consommateurs québécois ont le droit
de se faire servir en français mais l'on
passera dit qu'ils ont fait des efforts
pour s'améliorer
il ne donnait pas un service au niveau
nécessaire et là la mf va émettre pour
avoir des exigences vont surveiller le
travail des agences d'évaluation crédit
et c'est avec eux qu'on va travailler
c'est certain qu'il doit faire mieux les
obligations légales sont des jeunes pour
avoir accès donc au gel de dossiers puis
l alerte de sécurité pea ce service plus
efficace avec equifax et transunion va
falloir payer
oui et dans le cas qui qui fait
l'actualité c'est à dire la fuite de
données chez desjardins
c'est desjardins qui paient pour les
cinq prochaines années votre service
d'alertés ge si on est avec des jardins
exactement quels moyens financiers vous
donner à la mmf pour faire un travail
efficace là tu savais que la mf déjà
beaucoup de ressources et notre
régulateur intégrée du système financier
québécois et
il est ils ont des ressources qui vont
pouvoir faire ce travail ils ont
l'expertisé et si c'est nécessaire ils
pourront planifier les agences qu'elles
que la mmfs surveille pour avoir les
ressources nécessaires alors ça va
s'autofinancer
travaillez-vous à la mise en place d'une
identité numérique pour tous les
citoyens
oui ça c'est mon collègue éric caire le
ministre délégué à la transformation
numérique qui s'occupe des aspects de
cyber sécurité de d2 protection des
données gouvernementales et
l'authentification et l'identification
numérique
pour ce qui est de la protection des
renseignements personnels dans le
secteur privé ça c'est la ministre de la
justice
et ça c'est un collègue sonia lebel
d'ailleurs question ça brasse pas mal
chez desjardins ces jours-ci
congédiement de numéro deux du chef des
technologies je sais que vous voulez pas
commenter des décisions privées en tout
cas des décisions de l'entreprise mais
ce que vous avez toujours confiance dans
la gestion de crise actuellement chez
desjardins
oui mais c'est certain que healy a
présentement une enquête interne avec
des consultants externes desjardins
embaucher des consultants de qualité
pour revoir tous leurs processus et
revoir l'incident alors en amont en aval
est un processus d'amélioration continue
et la direction et le conseil
d'administration a décidé de faire des
changements et
le nouveau numéro 2 monsieur bellemare
c'est avec lui que nous allons avancer
est comme gelée mentionné moi je
m'attends à ce que des jardins adopte
les meilleures pratiques de l'industrie
au niveau de la gestion des risques de
la gouvernance du conseil
d'administration alors c'est une
évolution et ses changements love sont
en ligne avec ce monsieur le ministre
merci pour cet entretien ce soir je vous
remercie beaucoup merci